all right look Morty Kojima just wants
us to reconnect the fractured society
and stop the death stranding what are
all these goats those are the deaths
stranding rail okay yeah I wasn't paying
attention oh I we've been walking for a
while and I got this baby in a tube here
it's some sort of crazy upgrade hold on
I've got an idea
not an upgrade let's eat it we can't eat
it so baby what if it makes us run
faster jump higher okay let's eat the
baby yeah hey what's up guys what's up
guys and season four it's the forest of
all seasons
cuz it's the fourth one it's a lot
different from season three you've got a
lot of a lot of shoot-'em-ups a lot of
laser shoot-'em-ups and crystals little
monster I thought you were masturbating
you took that in stride there are old
faces coming back for a little bit more
of that old stuff that they did the
reason the you're getting five and then
a small break and then the back five is
because Turner Broadcasting warned us
about entertainment signal levels we had
all ten ready to go but we had to
legally cut it back to just five we did
some focused test screenings we showed
all ten episodes to a housewife from
Salt Lake City and her balls blew off
like after episode three it was just too
much we upped it by two episodes for the
skateboard crowd because they're more
extreme they drink Mountain Dew it's
really because if you watch them all
together in a row it's they're so good
it has a high effect on your deep
cellular tissue
Rick and Morty could actually literally
blow your balls off we missed all of our
deadlines you say you love Rick and
Morty
[Music]
before season 4 premieres on November 10
episodes from seasons 1 2 & 3 the Rick
and Morty binge Athan next Sunday from 9
p.m. to 5 a.m.
binge til the Sun comes up welcome back
everyone it's Charlie we have brand new
Rick and Morty season 4 footage to
breakdown they did a big death stranding
crossover and they released descriptions
for all of the episodes for the first
half of the season
so I'll be doing Easter egg videos all
season long if you're brand new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get the
videos and I will do merch giveaways in
all my Rick and Morty videos all you
have to do to enter those is just be a
subscriber and leave your best season 4
theory on the video just starting with
the Kojima death stranding crossover
footage if you're not familiar with
death stranding that's the game that
Kojima is releasing and actually I think
the next week if not the next couple of
days I love how quickly Morty turns
around on Rick's plan like no we have to
piece together these disparate pieces of
society left over after this giant
Cataclysm we have to keep this baby safe
well what if the baby gives us special
powers makes us run fast then not
wasting a minute okay let's totally eat
the baby there's also this one screen
grab that they posted to their Twitter
account saying that we're only allowed
to show you this and it's totally out of
context is just Jerry standing up to
Rick and Rick looking like he's really
pissed off that he has to take it it
does sort of harken back to what they
said about the new dynamic for season 4
which just like Beth said at the end of
season 3 is very much like the season 1
season 2 dynamic where he's the old
grandpa that they tolerate but they
don't question the fact that Morty goes
on adventures with him every week then
there's all that brand new footage from
the other promo new footage of Professor
poopy butthole fighting his students off
in the classroom there's new footage of
them flying through this asteroid field
then this scene of the snakes shooting
the other snake you probably recognize
as a parody of the first Terminator
movie which I guess makes Morty there
Sarah Connor this snake is wearing the
exact same shirt in jacket is Kyle Reese
and has the same ability to work a
shotgun just as well and this snake has
the cybernetic looking Terminator red
eyes like the t100 hard to tell which
episode this correlates to but then
there's more footage of the me
seeks scene for some reason Morty hits
the button on the meeseeks box but Ricky
yells added to kill Morty r.i.p Rivoli
o´clock burg then there's this new scene
of rick yelling at morty about stealing
death crystals which they also reference
during this akira reference scene later
in the trailer looking like it gives
Morty some sort of akira like abilities
this scene is just more of them at that
lush planet from the last trailer then
dan and justin both a joke about why
Adult Swim is only advertising five
episodes before the break everybody is
asking this and they're like what's the
deal with them only saying five episodes
he blames the break on lame audience
members in the Midwest like he talks
about mom's than the skateboard crowd
but really it's the exact same thing
they did during season one breaking the
season in half they aired season 1 at
the end of the year then what happened
is they went on break for a couple weeks
during the Christmas and New Year's
holiday then they came back for the rest
of the episodes the second half of the
season at the end of January so they
might just do the exact same thing but
Justin does confirm go on a little break
after the first five episodes then come
back so it's not like there's only gonna
be five episodes total they're supposed
to be ten total episodes in season four
Justin makes fun of them for blowing all
their deadlines but they are actually
working on season five episodes already
while they're in post-production on the
last couple of episodes for season four
so don't worry it's not like they're
behind schedule or anything like that
that's just them poking fun at
themselves for how slow they used to be
there was also another brand new clip
that they dropped during the Adult Swim
development meeting recently I can't
post the complete clip here but it was
basically Morty getting bit in outer
space while they were changing one of
the tires on Rick's spaceship in the
dead of space Rick tells Morty to be
careful what could possibly hurt us out
here because there's nothing around them
then all of a sudden this space snake
that you see dead on the dashboard just
winds its way up and bites Morty through
his space suit
Rick yells at him to get back in the
spaceship then you get the scene of
Morty complaining about dying in Rick
complaining about Morty's complaining
before they get back to the garage and
he tells them not to put too much of the
ointment on himself or he'll have to
hunt what he becomes
which he then totally does and Rick just
slowly pulls his gun out everyone pull
out your voucher for one free
replacement Morty the last promo is just
a special Rick and Morty marathon that
Adult Swim is running Sunday in honor of
the season 4 episode 1 premiere so they
might drop some new footage in
middle of that if they do I'll totally
do a new Easter egg video for it but
recently they also just released
official descriptions of the first five
episodes all the ones that are airing
before the Christmas holiday because
technically season four is meant to be
ten episodes but they're just promoting
the first half of it before the big
holiday break some of these are real
gems and you'll see and they're listed
in order so it's season four episode 1
through episode 5 going down the list
edge of to Morty rick died repeat Morty
goes nuts this time dog Rick does stuff
season 4 premiere bro the title edge of
tomorrow Rick died repeat is a reference
to edge of tomorrow the Tom Cruise movie
based on the Japanese manga all you need
is kill it sounds like he or Rick or
both of them might wind up dying
repeatedly but the description only
mentions Morty going crazy in this and
my earlier theory was is that it would
be the chachi episode of them running
from the aliens just because there's a
big alien threat in edge of tomorrow
season 4 episode 2 the old man in the
seat we all have one thing in common bro
I don't know bro watch this one
surprisingly unhelpful description but
the title is a reference to Ernest
Hemingway's the old man in the sea is
the story of an old man trying to catch
a giant fish in the battle that he has
with it since Rick spends so much of his
time in the promo though in that special
hover chair pretty safe bet that the
title is a reference to that in the
episode season four episode three one
crew over the cuckoo's Morty lots of
twists and turns this time bro wear your
helmets also a description that's not
super helpful but it might be related to
the Akira's situation reference that
they make during the trailer with morty
battling people behind the mall and then
summer and beth fighting each other on
that airport tarmac Captain America
Civil War style
claun horror Special Victims Morty Morty
gets a dragon in this one bro it's a
wild ride bro the title is a reference
to Law & Order Special Victims Unit they
confirm in the description that this is
the one where Morty gets a dragon that
Rick is talking about during the trailer
but it's kind of hard to connect any of
the other trailer footage to what's
going on inside the living room here
when they're talking about the dragon
Law & Order Special Victims Unit is the
show that ice-t is on but I don't know
if they have any plans to bring back the
water tee character from get schwifty
they joked in the commentary about that
about how the story that they did in the
post-credits scene could have been their
new Game of Thrones like maybe we should
do some more with that with that
intergalactic war that they keep
referencing then season 4 episode 5
ral star rick lactic ax lots of things
happen in space bro snakes and sharp
stuff watch this bro the title of the
episode is a reference to Battlestar
Galactica but it also specifically
mentions space snakes in the description
so that's from this episode with the
dead space snake wearing the spacesuit
that had just bitten Morty if you
spotted any other big Easter eggs and
the trailers that I didn't mention in
the video just post them below in the
comments and Rick and Morty season 4
episode 1 will be releasing on November
12 so it's almost just a week away since
they post those episodes so late at
night
all my easter egg videos for the
episodes will post monday mornings as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see the videos
whenever I post them but leave all your
bonus video requests or if you have any
big questions you want me to include in
videos congratulations Sean pero you're
the giveaway winner from my last Rick
and Morty video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details
everyone click here for that last pic
Rick and Morty trailer with all the
fourth wall break scenes and click here
for my giant Rick and Morty season 4
playlist thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]